Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
authored by
we are in the sixth chapter and the
final narration in the sixth chapter.
It's the 73rd consecutive narration. It
is the
fifth narration in the chapter. The
chapter being the chapter of a tawa, the
chapter of righteousness, reverence
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, obedience
of Allah and adherence to his command,
abstinence from his prohibitions
in order that a person may be spared
from Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala's anger
and punishment.
forch.
[Silence]
He says on the authority of
who narrates, I heard the messenger of
Allah. Wasam
giving his address, giving his or one of
his on the day or during the farewell
pilgrimage.
One thing that's important to note here
is that there wasn't just one
during
oftent times we are aware of the
very famous that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam gave on mounta on the
day of where he began with the verses
This is of course the most prominent or
one of the most prominent of his
addresses during
but actually there were quite a few
addresses that he made during and
rightfully so. Why? Because
was the first, last, and only time that
he was to give
in Hajj that he was to make Hajj saiam.
He only he only had this chance to make
Hajj and the bulk majority of the Muslim
at the time had all congregated there in
Mecca to make Hajj with him sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. And so this was one of
the rare occasions which most of the
Arab tribes that had accepted Islam,
most of the most prominent Muslim
leaders and tribesmen
and Muslim men had all gathered there
in
and so it was an opportunity for him to
teach and address and connect and
instruct. And so there were quite a few
addresses that he made during
is this one here
the same as
the very famous one on
not necessarily and that's why you may
find many narrations that say during
he said this during
He gave and said this you find that it
it is not
you know in accordance with that very
famous
that very famous u mention of the
wording of that. might think you know
is this incomplete was was there parts
of it that were left out no there were
many that he gave during
as a matter of fact some scholars have
authored books only compiling the that
he gave during
and they are numerous
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said during
He addressed the people saying,
"So this is the first commandment. This
is the general
the general advice that he addressed
the people with
and pray your five meaning your five
daily prayers
and fast your month meaning your yearly
month of Ramadan
and hand over the zak that is owed
from your wealth
and obey your leaders and those in
authority amongst you.
If you do so, you will enter the
paradise of your Lord.
So most of us are
you know in today today speaking in
today's world many people
pray their five daily prayers they
fast their month of Ramadan they give
the zaky of their wealth but then we get
to this hiccup
and obey those in authority amongst you
and Here we have a very rare instance
where people will obey their leaders,
those in authority amongst them. This is
part
of the tenants of Islam.
This is something that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasallam
mentioned along with the most prominent
rights of Islam which are the five
pillars of Islam.
Yet what do we chronically suffer from
today?
We suffer from
we suffer from a lack of obedience
to our to those in authority amongst
us. It's almost it's a dirty word.
It's almost it's you know, how
could we? Of course not. We have the the
spirit of rebellion and the spirit of
anarchy and power to the people. And
where has it gotten us? The
disbelievers, those who are our sworn
enemies, have managed to topple our own
civilization
with our hands.
With our hands.
So when the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
says, "And obey
those in authority amongst you."
This is speaking about obedience. How
much more so
if a person were to actively disobey?
What about if a person were to actively
revolt?
And this is an issue that we don't even
suffer from on a countrywide scale or a
regional government scale. We suffer
from even in the most basic and simple
of scales
for instance the im and salah. Does
he fall into the generality of this
statement and obey those in authority
amongst you and you are praying behind
someone they are leading in you in
salah. Is this a a type of leadership?
This is a type of leadership. Very
specific type of leadership. It's a type
of leadership and how obedient and
adherent do you find people generally
speaking even in that simple scenario
where don't go before the imam don't go
along with the imam you follow the imam
right it's a tossup many people struggle
with even this even this
let alone the struggle that scholars go
through with respect to
the people following their
direction. There's a lot of sund
and the idea is who is this to be
over me and tell me what to do. Everyone
is a chief. And as they say in America,
everyone is a chief. And we don't have
any Indians. We have no Indians.
Everyone wants to be the guy giving the
commands. Nobody wants to be the one who
receives them. Everyone wants to be the
general. No soldiers. Everyone wants to
be the chief. No Indians. Everyone wants
to be the rooster. No hens. None. Who is
this? Who is going to tell me
me
what to do? I don't have to. I don't
have to. I don't need to. If I don't
what the scholar says, I'll just go
to another one. If I don't this
masid, I'll just go to another one. If I
don't this person, I'll just go to
another one. If I don't this imam,
I'll just get him out of there and put a
new one in. Right? because we have drank
the Kool-Aid of democracy.
That's the democracy, right? But it
doesn't work that in these other
countries. The prophets Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala described
those whom he loves.
Those whom Allah loves and they love
him. What is their description?
Oh, you skip something. You skip
something big.
[Silence]
Very deliberate order there.
They are prominence
in face of disbelief and the
disbelievers.
They are
humble and
they are humble and gentle with the
believers.
I'll give you an example.
If your average
everyday run-of-the-mill religious guy,
he makes salah, he gives zaka, etc.
If the
if a judge from a Muslim court from a
you know from the district court calls
him or the clerk
or
someone appointed by the court or a
lawyer or the secretary or the janitor
from the court calls him, will he take
that call? Will he answer that call? If
he is told you are to be at court
tomorrow at 8:00, what time will he show
up?
He will. The 7:45 is late. He'll be here
6:00 in the morning. You ever see the
the American US embassy? You ever see
people show up there? Huh? Their
appointment is at 8. They'll be there at
2 in the morning, buttoned up, ready to
go.
All right.
If
an imam or a Muslim scholar were to call
this same person, can they get through?
Come, I want to see you. I want to speak
to you. What is it?
Who are you? I You know what? I talked
to that guy. I knew that guy. I don't I
don't that guy. I I don't know what
kind of scholars these we have this
indoctrination that we have. It's almost
as if it is positively
weak
to be adherent or obedient to one
another.
Except when it is an outsider
in a in a position of authority over us.
We are on our P's and Q's.
This is what we call crab. Crabs in a
barrel.
When you take crabs, you put them
inside of a barrel. It's the most
fascinating thing. If one of them climbs
and is going to get out, the other ones
reach up and pull them back in. You're
not going anywhere. If we can't leave,
you're not leaving. Right? This is why
we say crabs in a barrel.
And so it has become what? Switched.
Not all Muslims. Of course, this is
much too broad of a generality. But the
point is is that this is one of the most
prominent descriptions of the believers
that the prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam came to correct in the jah
Arabs. You look at the Arabs in Jahia,
they were schisomed into tribes
and each tribe had a chief and each
chief had and they were in constant
conflict and war with one another.
What did they all all the tribes agree
on? What did all the tribes agree on?
Adherence to the Romans,
adherence to the Persians. And so they
were sometimes
swallowed up by the Romans, sometimes
swallowed up by the Persians. Never
their own. Never. It was not even
considered to be within the realm of
reality
for the Arab tribes to go against the
Romans ever or go against the Persians.
It was a given. And the only reason the
Romans and Persians hadn't completely
invaded and occupied the Arab peninsula
is because there was nothing there. It
was just desert. What do we want with
it? They stopped in Hashem and that was
as far as they went because they had no
interest in going any further. And if
they wanted to, they would,
right? And Yemen was most of the time
taken up and swallowed up by the by
the neshi by the Ethiopians at the time.
The Arabs had no kingdom, no king, no
hierarchy, nothing. It was a source of
pride that who is this tribe to to be in
authority over me? Right? And the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam came
and completely annihilated that ideology
and so it became a source of pride for
the mmin that he adheres to authority
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would say things this
just five daily prayers is part of
what is going to get you into paradise
guys.
That's right next to it, right along
with it.
However,
when we become
psychologically occupied and colonized,
we mentioned this a few days ago, how we
all come from countries that have been
destroyed, pulverized
by occupation and colonization.
One of the most important things that
the colonizer will drive into the the
DNA
of the individual
that they have colonized is you are
never to accept authority from your own
self. You will only accept us as the
authority.
And we learn it. We learned the lesson
ever since we are crawling around on the
ground before we even learn how to walk.
We learn from the way that our parents
are startled at the thought of the colon
colonist government even thinking of or
considering
us as being disobedient.
And we watch the way that there is no
authority from amongst us. The only
authority comes from from outside of us.
And so now we can't even hardly keep a
masid together. I've been to massid
where
there's a masid in Queens where they
have two imams,
maybe more, fighting with each other.
Every couple months they overthrow one
and kick him out. And when I say kick
him out, I don't mean just I mean
physically have the police come and
remove him on Jum. Each group brings in
their own member and has autbah going on
simultaneously
yelling the at each other and they
change the direction of the in the masid
more than 20 times in five years.
That's a real place. And that's not one
or two places that I've been to like
this. Obviously, this is an extreme
case, but
many places. Why? Because the colonizer
has
put it into us that you only submit to
the black ling ring lords when they come
from you when you're a little kid. Look
at how even in schools today, we have
active shooter drills where men show up
with loaded loaded fully automatic
weapons dressed in black head to toe.
Get on your knees. Put your hands on
your head. Walk slowly. We train them.
We train a citizenship to only fear
this one government. everyone else. We
we teach the wife to revolt against the
husband and the child to revolt against
the the mother and father. We treat we
we teach the child to revolt against his
parents or her parents. We teach the
student to revolt against the teacher.
Ultimate authority is only
to the dark ring lords. everyone else.
Who are they to tell you anything?
And so when can we ever get this
operation off the ground? Never. Never.
Subhan
Allah. We will complete the next chapter
in a day or two and then we will move
on to chapters regarding fasting and the
rulings of fasting and so forth
leading up to Ramadan for the next
couple of weeks inshallah.
You want to mention something?
[Arabic recitation]